[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns on here welcome to the
thirty fifth episode of my dirty chess
tricks in this episode I am going to
show you a very tricky line and in fact
a mini recruit are against nimza Larsson
opening which start with the mu B 3 if
you are playing a professional chess
tournament then you should have a good
replica against it as this opening is
frequently appearing on the board by
many strong players now as usual the
setup I'm going to recommend contains a
great surprise value but the most
important point I like about it it
allows white what he actually wants to
do and still get him lot of trouble and
even though let's say you open and
doesn't fall for the tricks in most of
the lines black get a slightly
advantageous position ok so let's get
started my recommendation here is you
should continue with the movie file and
after Bishop to b2 attacking if I black
should continue with Knight to c6 white
place III so liberating his of the
bishop and now you grab the center with
a defy the main line continue with
Bishop to b5 so pinning the night thus
threatening the e5 square so black needs
to support it with Bishop to d6 and now
white reveal his idea that is a4 so you
can see in the opening white is having a
lot of fun he's putting a lot of
pressure on the black setup and that's
why it is very dangerous if you don't
know the theory now here black has tried
many options such as Queen to e7 or
Queen to h4 but I don't like them so
instead of those my recommendation is
this tricky move AB 6 epics limits the
white option and in most of the line now
it is white who has to play some careful
moves to avoid lots of pitfalls here
mainly 2 options has been tried and
let's look each in detail the first move
I want to consider is F captures Aoife
which looks more natural because after F
captures ePHI this is a very tactical
line where I think black is coming out
on top in almost all the variations the
first move I want to consider is Bishop
captures c6 and after pawn captures c6
white can play this tricky move Bishop
captures ePHI which happens in many many
games white simple idea is if black take
this Bishop then after Queen h5 not only
white will regain the piece but at this
position but is a clear pawn up and this
is something black should certainly
avoid but instead of Bishop captures
ePHI here black has a better move Queen
to h4 which completely destroy a white's
tactical idea and in fact by force black
is winning in almost all the variations
if King moves anywhere then Bishop will
drop so force replies g3 and now black
has this little move Queen to e4 so
attacking to piece here the base
response is Bishop captures d6 which I
have covered in detail in the PGN so
kindly go through it but in the database
all the games here onwards
continue with Bishop captures g7 which
is more natural as white is saying that
ok we both can grab the rook in the
corner and the resulting position is
better for the white well I'm afraid
it's not that easy
because after Queen captures rook Queen
to h5 check so white is definitely miss
placing the black king and after king to
e7 as I have highlighted over here white
has tried this four options if King to
have fun the Knight to f6 is a very
strong reply so let's see what happens
if white plays other three moves
to give you a brief idea in two
variations black will now fight Queen
and in one munition black is nabbing a
piece so you can understand the pain
white will get in this video let's look
at the first obvious response Bishop
captures a eight well after this the
line is very easy you capture the piece
with a check came to e2 Queen G to check
if King to d3 then Queen to e4 is a very
strong reply so accordingly white needs
to keep the king in the back rank King
to even and now the star move BAM
why doesn't have any options White has
to take this piece and after Queen check
King to have fun bishop checked King to
e2 and finally Bishop to g4 nabbing the
white sweetie
the second option is king - f2 which is
more natural
protecting the peace but once again
black has this lethal shot Bishop
captures g3 if King takes g3 then white
is going to lose to peace so accordingly
white is forced to move the King well it
doesn't matter whether King goes to
their fun or e2 both will be treated
with equal response let's say in this
game
white continue with the move e - and
after at six black has created escape
route for his rook so white has to take
this look now but then comes this
forcing sequence which by force winds
White Queen before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find out a
sequence where you can win actually
whites Queen did you find it
let's see Quinn check King to d3 Queen
to e4 check and now it doesn't matter
whether King goes to the c3 or e2 let's
say in this game white plays King to c3
but after Bishop to g4 the queen is a
corner finally what happens if Queen to
h4 check well this is very easy because
after King to f7 black is attacking the
bishop
so what responds his force but has to
take the rook in the corner but as
happened in other lines after Queen
check King to e2 Queen check King to d3
Bishop to a5 check King to c3 and now
Queen to e4 threatening our mate
so what has to forcefully exchange the
Queen and in the resulting position
black is a clear piece of so these are
some of the wonderful tactical line if
you open and greedily capture the e5
pawn
more stable reply over here is Knight to
f3 so white idea is capturing the e5
pawn after castling as this pawn is not
going anywhere because of the pin well
that's true but black has equally strong
reply night 2 at 6:00 once again we need
to check out what happens if you open
and take this ePHI pawn which is not
good because of the simple Queen check
and after g3 this time around Queen to
e4 doesn't work but black has a strong
reply Queen to chief I so now this
Knight is hanging so white response is
force either he has to protect the
knight or play this tactical move Knight
to c6 which in fact doesn't turn out
well because of this lethal blow yep
Bishop captures g3 if King moves then as
I have highlighted by the arrows it will
be checked by the black pieces so only
the good reply over here is H captures
g3 afterwards Queen captures g3 King to
a fun rook to a fit check came to e2
and Bishop to g4 as usual the white
sweetie will disappear from the border
so Knight captures c6 looks good but in
fact is a complete disaster for the
white so accordingly d4 is a fitting
reply well afterwards black will
continue with his lightning fast
development castle on the Kings side so
stopping by to castle on the Kings side
and there is a thread on e3 so white
need to defend this with Queen to d2 and
after this black get a very comfortable
game with a knight captures ePHI I
reached this position against a 2100
rated player where after this capture
few pieces get exchanged by place D
capture c5 Bishop captures ePHI Bishop
captures e-file Queen captures ePHI if
Knight to c3 then c6 is a very strong
reply so in the game
upon and desperately want to exchange
the Queen but I was more than happy as
African Queen captures pawn captures c6
Bishop to d3 Bishop to a5 Bishop
captures fr and Knight captures fi yes
there's a balance material in the
position but if you carefully look at it
white is in a lot of trouble white
cannot castle because d4 pawn drops and
to illustrate the danger in this
position white continue with the move
c3 I respond with the moon my to e3 so
there is a threat of night to c2 which
my opponent parry with King to d2 which
looks perfectly reasonable but there
comes Knight Shaq King to Devin and now
rook to f2 and as we all know rook on
the second ring is a monster piece
my upper ends position quickly fallen
apart after just one moon my two III and
rook to e8 and those rooks were never
connected in the game and black had all
the fun in this game so once again white
cannot take the e5 pawn so white has to
Castle Faust and after black castle now
if white wishes he can pick the pawn
after Bishop captures e6 pawn capture c6
and Knight captures ePHI so at first
sight it looks like wow we've in a pond
right what is the big idea well just for
one pawn black get tremendous attack on
white King and which can be illustrated
via two different more David Hall one of
the leading England Grandmaster reach
this position in one of his game where
he continued with the move Bishop to f5
so you can see the easy attacking scheme
by black he wants to play Queen to g5
and then start pressurizing the King
side his opponent doesn't like this idea
so he immediately played Queen to h5
stopping both the Queen intruder square
but in fact it turns out that this is a
big time blunder by white before I move
on I like you to pause this video and
find out what is the wrong with the move
Queen to h5
well I hope you do and find this
accurate sequence Bishop captures ePHI
Bishop captures ePHI and now Bishop to
g4 and as happens in many of the cases
this queen is strapped on h5 well what
to do right indeed managed to rescue his
queen after following order that his
rook check King to f8 Bishop chair came
to g7 and Queen to e5 but the net result
is he has to give up peace for a to pawn
which is not a good trade and in fact
after few moves black easily converted
the win while Bishop to fr is a
completely playable move in this
position my recommendation is you play
this tactical move rook captures have
fun here my response is Force One cannot
take with the King because after Queen
to f6 Queen to f3 and Bishop captures
ePHI black is simply been a piece so
that's not good so Queen captures f1 is
forced and now you play Queen to G Phi
attacking twice on the fi night and if
Knight captures c6 then Knight to g4 and
that attack is very potent so
accordingly the best response over here
is Queen to f4 naturally white wants to
exchange the Queen because he is a clear
pawn up and black accordingly declined
the Queen exchange with Queen to h5
there's a threat on d1 so white needs to
parry with Knight - III and now very
strong move Bishop to e6 so you can see
all the moves are very much forced and
just for a1 pawn black at tremendous
attacking fun position which over the
board not easy to defend to illustrate
my point I like to show you one of my
blitz game from this position against a
2,200 rated player where my opponent
plays the obvious move d4
he anticipating my rook f ed mu so
that's why he is providing extra
protection to his Knight
well no metal roof to f8 happen
attacking the Queen Queen to g3 and now
very good move Knight to g4
so more pcs are joining into the attack
and if s 3 then Knight 2 f2 is a very
strong reply so in the game
white continue with the move rook to
even I responded with Knight 2 f2 and my
opponent plays rook to have fun
attacking tonight now black screen
entered into the white cuts with Queen -
E - so black has a simple threat of
Knight to h3 and then nabbing the rope
on their fun and also white cannot play
rook captures f2 because of the Queen to
even check considering all the options
my opponent continued here with rook to
be even so getting out of any discovery
I continue with night - Devon so now my
simple threat is rook to f1 checkmate
which my opponent parry with the moon h3
but nevertheless rook to f1 happen King
to edge to Knight captures be - if I
capture the rook then black is a clear
piece up so my opponent captured this
piece but that allows the infiltration
on the back rank with Quinn - Devon so
there is a mid threatened so my opponent
played Queen to G Phi giving his King
some breathing room but after rook check
King to g3 Queen check King to f4 and
rook to effing deliver a finest King
dance major
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
first part of my mini reputa against
nimza larsen opening stay tuned for the
next episode where we are going to look
what happens if you open in place Queen
to h5 line thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on this video and I will meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care